>>Female Presenter: Hello. Good afternoon.
My name is Alana Weiss, and
today it is my pleasure to welcome Robert
Steven Kaplan
to the Leading@Google series. Rob is a professor
of
management practice at the Harvard Business
School and
prior to joining HBS he served as the vice
chairman of
the Goldman-Sachs group with oversight responsibility
for the investment banking and investment
management
divisions. Rob is also currently Google's
chairman of
the investment advisory committee. Please
join me in
welcoming Rob.
[Clapping]
>>Rob Kaplan: Thanks, Alana, and thanks for
having me. Just out of curiosity given that
you're here
on your lunch break, how many of you feel
stressed out?
Stressed out. Losing sleep at night? Really?
Worry?
That's not good. I'm sorry to hear that. What
are you
worried -- just throw out a few things. What
worried about? Those who raised their hand,
what are
you so worried about? All right. So you're
juggling
too many things. Okay. Which is what we were
talking
about before. Others? Any others? What's that?
Insurance settlement. Okay. All right. What
else?
How many of you manage a project, or a project
team, or
people? How many of you would like to manage
a project,
project team, or people? All right. Okay.
Here's what
I'm going to do. Not to spoil your lunch,
first of all.
Here's what I'm going to talk about. I'm going
through
just six or seven slides. I'm going to try
actually not
to talk for more than 30, 35 minutes, then
we're going to
leave the rest of the time to questions, things
you want
to talk about. The reason I'm doing this is,
this is
actually a version of a talk I've been giving
for the past 25
years for better or worse because I learned
a long time
ago in leading businesses, leading non-profits,
working
with organizations, I realized I was never
going to
ultimately figure out all the answers. And
as the world
gets more complex and you're in a very complicated
business, as a leader, no matter how smart
you are,
experienced you are, you're never going to
have all the
answers. You're never going to understand
well enough
to be telling people what they ought to be
doing in a
lot of cases, and what you don't want to do
is be
ordering people to do things and be wrong.
And so what
I've learned over the years is the most important
thing
a leader can do is learn to ask the right
questions, be
open to learning. There are times to give
orders and
advocate and say this is what we're going
to do, but the
stronger leaders know when to do that and
also know when
to ask questions. And so what I'm going to
do here
is go through -- this whole book is about
how to ask
those questions, and it's basically about
if you want to
run an organization, you want to be a leader,
you want
to be a project manager, you want to manage
your life,
here's your road map for doing it, and it's
in the form
of questions with stories about how to do
it. Okay? So
that's what I'm going to talk about. And it's
going to
be -- and you may thing that Harvard Business
School is
a very sophisticated place. You're going to
be sorely
disappointed. Your going to basically see,
at least with
me. Maybe not with them. But you're going
to see that
the basic questions you need to ask, I think,
to be an
outstanding leader, are brutally simple. And
I mean
really simple. That does not mean they're
easy to do.
They're not easy to do. All right. And by
the way,
where did these pictures come from? I literally
went on
Google, [audience chuckles] and for every
title I picked a picture that
resonated with me and boom, put it in there.
So if you
don't like them, you can't blame the graphics
firm. All
right. Here's -- here's the first point. This
is true
for everybody and most of us, including me,
don't think
about this. If you -- as a leader, the first
thing I
would argue you need to think about and for
each of you
what is your aspiration? What is your vision?
What is
it you want to accomplish? Now, let me just
ask you,
how many here in this room have a vision for
themselves,
for their business, for the project they're
working on?
Okay. That's a -- that's great. A lot of people
don't
think about what their vision is. And let
me just say
to you, there's two things I talk to leaders
about.
Number one, can you write down on a piece
of paper your
aspiration? So all of you who raised your
hand -- I'm
not going to call on you, don't worry -- but
can you
write it down clearly? Okay. Number two, can
your
people, the people that you're working with,
can they
write it down? If I gave them a quiz, could
they write
down the same vision that you just wrote down?
Here's
why this is important. First of all, I would
argue that
every successful business I've ever seen -- or
non-profit -- a lot of people think that successful
businesses are because people are so shrewd,
that
they're focused on how to make money, they're
commercially smart. Not really. They ultimately
need
to do those things, but those come way down
the list.
Successful, sustainable businesses that I've
seen start
with a vision about how to serve a client,
or make a
positive impact on the world. And they're
based on a
clear distinctive competence. Now, I don't
need to tell
you this because at Google [chuckles] you
know this already. You
focus on this every day. But a lot of business
leaders
don't, and a key to a successful project,
leader, or
leader at all, is to stay with that vision,
or update it
if you need to update it, but everything you
do needs to
revolve around that, and the people you're
working with
need to know what it is. Because it is very
hard to
mobilize people if they don't know your aspiration.
So
to me the first thing you've got to do as
a leader is
can you write it down clearly? Do you articulate
it to
the people you're working with? You may not
have people
working for you. You may not have people reporting
to
you. The people working on your team, the
people across
departments, do you tell them what the vision
is so
you're on the same page, and could they repeat
it back?
Now, I could argue -- I'll take an example.
Barack Obama
was elected President of the United States,
in my opinion,
in 2008 because he articulated a very clear
vision for
where he wanted to take the country. And to
me that
vision was not changed. That was mechanic.
It was
unification. We're going to find a new way
to do
things; we're all going to come together.
Some of you
are too young, but you remember the speech
that he gave
at the 2004 convention: "There's not a black
American;
not a white American; not a rich American...
there's
just the United States of America." Visionary
candidate. Very clear on what he wanted to
do. Very
clear aspiration. You should ask yourself
-- people ask
gee, a lot of people accuse Obama today of
not being a
strong leader. Why? And it takes a little
thought, but
for me, I think people are not clear on what
his vision
is for lots of reasons, but it shows you how
important
it is if you're a project leader, if you're
the head of
the household, or if you're the President
of the United
States, it starts with a clear vision. Okay?
So that's
number one. By the way, these are questions.
So the
reason I write these questions, if you're
struggling or
you can't seem to mobilize your people, or
your unit
isn't doing well and you're wondering why,
what this is
intended to be is keep five or six questions
on your
wall. Maybe I'm not clear enough on the vision.
Maybe
the world has changed and I haven't changed
the vision.
Maybe I have a vision; I'm not repeating it
enough and
my people aren't clear. Maybe I'd better repeat
it at
the next meeting and that's the problem. So
this is
like a pilot on a plane checklist of what
might be wrong
when they're having engine trouble. This is
number one
question. This is the cornerstone for me of
everything
you do. I teach at Harvard Business School.
I want to
be the best professor in the world. Okay?
I do. It's
pathetic, but I do. [laughter] That is my
dream. It really is.
And everything I do is to try to -- we'll
see if I get
there, but that doesn't matter. At he's I
know what I'm
trying to do and it has a powerful impact
on everything
that I do. Okay. Now, once you have a vision,
there's
one other thing that's got to go with it,
and that is
you have to pick three -- in my opinion three
to five
key tasks -- I call them priorities here,
but what I
really mean, what are the most important things
you must
do superbly well to achieve that vision? And
same
question: Can you write them down? How many
think you
could write down the top three? Okay. Interesting.
Not as many. So you're clear on the vision,
but not as
clear on the priorities. And I would argue
you've got
to be clear on the priorities for one big
reason, which
I'm about to get to. How do you spend your
time? How
many of you are working 70 hours a week; stressed
out
because you're working 70 hours a week? No?
[chuckles] Sixty?
All the ones that are -- okay. Sixty. Fine.
Fifty.
Whatever. But you're juggling a lot. Here's
the point.
When people are struggling on how to spend
their time or
I have a business leader or anyone come to
me and say
"Oh, my God, I'm just juggling so many things
I don't
know what to do. How do you do it? I'm just
trying to
squeeze these things in." And by the way,
I'll say
them, "Well, what's your vision for the business?"
And
they say, "Oh, Rob, I don't think about it.
I'm just
too busy." Okay. Well can you tell me your
three to
five top priorities? "Oh, Rob. The chaos of
this
business I can't even think about it." And
I go oy. I
say to them -- I go listen, the -- this is
part of your
problem. Clear vision and then you've got
to write down
three to five priorities. Now, some of you
may say,
"Rob, you couldn't understand. We've got ten
or fifteen
priorities." I've had people say that to me
and I would
say politely back, ten to fifteen priorities
is the same
as zero. Zero. That's zero. Okay? And why
do I say
that? It's not that I don't have a to-do list
of ten or
fifteen things, but a human being, no matter
how talented, at
any one point, it's hard to really bore in
on three, or
four, or five. And it's critical. The most
important
asset you have is your time. A lot of people
think it's
money, it's hard assets, it's all this other
stuff. I
believe strongly the most important asset
all of you
have as leaders is your time. Yet many of
us spend our
time in a very sloppy way. And one little
rule I give
for people, pretend that this time was a big
sum of money, a lot of money.
Whatever's a lot of money to you. Pretend
that you were
going to think about how to spend it. I will
bet you
just looking at this group you don't just
oh, here let's
spend X-thousand here, X-thousand there. Who
does that?
Nobody does it. You really think -- some of
you really
think hard before you spend any of it. I would
argue
the irony is, if you do that with your money,
this is
more valuable I would argue even than your
money, or
it's the same thing. Why don't you do it the
same way?
And there's only one way that I know how.
You've got to
decide in advance what your top priorities
are, and then
you've got to match your time with those priorities.
When I see a business leader, or a non-profit
leader, or
a project manager, you name it, who's having
trouble,
invariably, lack of a clear vision or they've
got it but
do not think about matching their time with
their top
priorities. Why? A, they just don't think
about it; B,
they haven't written down their top three
to five
priorities. But I can tell you if you don't
know your
top three to five priorities, I am pretty
certain you
are poorly using your time because it takes
enormous
effort. If people are asking you to do things
all the
time, like they were with me -- they still
are. Unless
you know what you're trying to do, you've
got to know
who to say no to. You've got to learn how
to say no.
The question is, who do you say no to? Unless
you've
decided in advance, it's hard to say no to
people. How
many of you actually -- I won't even ask.
I've got an
idea. If you asked me how I spent my time
this last
week, I would not have the slightest idea.
How many of
you think you know? And how many of you don't
know?
All right. How many of you got like a shoulder
problem
or something?
[Laughing]
>>Rob Kaplan: All right. Okay. We'll leave
you alone on that. You're eating lunch. But
let me
tell you something. The other advice I'd give
you if
you're like me, go for a week and track how
you spend
your time. It's annoying to do, but do it
anyhow.
Track within chunks how you spend your time,
and then
write it down at the end of the week. Match
those
chunks with those top priorities and see how
far off you
are. Now, the one other thing if it helps
-- I talk
about this in the book, and this is simple
stuff. One
of the things I've done for CEOs of large
organizations
all the way to, you know, just independent
project
managers is ask them to break their tasks,
the things
they're spending time on, into ones, twos,
and threes.
Ones are things you've got to do. And I'm
going to talk
about that in a moment. For example, I believe
you've
got to decide on your vision of priorities.
If you're
not making time for that, you've got to do
that. That's
a one. Then there's twos and threes. Twos
are things
yeah, maybe, maybe not; and threes are things
you
absolutely should not be doing. There's no
--
there's -- I've talked to CEOs who are still
approving
expenses down to blank-thousand dollars. Why?
Well,
it's just what we've always done. How many
hours a week
does it take? Fifteen. You know. And yet they
don't
have time to do the very basic things we need
them to
do -- you need them to do. So I just say to
you, track
it for a week, break it into one, twos, and
threes,
match it with your priorities, and see what
the match or
mismatch is. To me, if you do nothing beyond
sitting
here for lunch today, if you can write down
your vision,
your top priorities, and you work on matching
your time,
there's a bunch of other things that we're
going to talk
about but that I've seen. That alone can make
somebody
who's good a lot better immediately. As simple
as it
is. All right. Okay. Now once -- by the way,
my
definition of leadership, just for what it's
worth given
I asked if you wanted -- who all -- I talk
about
leadership, I teach leadership. My definition
of
leadership for purposes of this speech, and
this book,
and everything I do, all leadership is to
me is working
on deciding what you believe, which a lot
of times is
not an easy thing to do. Sometimes you're
just not
sure. You have a strong point of view. Getting
conviction, making the effort to get conviction
on what
you believe, and then having the courage to
act on it.
That's leadership. And by that definition,
you don't
need to manage anybody to be a leader. You
could be a
single head of household, you could be a double
head of
household, you could be in the service, you
could be a
policeman or woman, you could be a project
manager or
professional working at Google. There are
many leaders
in this room. There's millions leaders in
this country.
People ask where all the leaders are. There's
lots of
them. Here's the problem: Just because you
manage
thousands of people, which I did in my career,
also does
not mean you're a leader because you can manage
thousands of people and not make the effort
to truly
decide what you believe or have the courage
to act on
it. So there are people that are in positions
of power
that are not acting like leaders, and there's
many
people who have no position of power but do
exert
leadership. And so everything that I talk
about today
is how do you do it. And I would argue a great
company
is one where the leaders do this, but they
create an
environment in the whole organization where
people are
not afraid to speak up and act like leaders,
express --
decide what they believe and act on it. And
I know
that -- I believe as an outsider that strikes
me as one
of the critical success factors to Google
and why this
company has done so well. All right. All these
things
are intended to make you more effective at
that. So
vision, priorities, how you're spending your
time.
Okay. Now, once you've got those three, now
you're
ready to coach people and you're ready to
get coaching.
How many of you have a coach? How many of
you are a
coach? All right. All right. So let me just
comment
on this. First of all, to me, coaching when
I say
coaching I'm just talking about people you
work with, do
you identify one or two skill-related things
that they
need to do better and confront them with it
and discuss
it with them, and then hopefully give them
one or two
ways to improve? That, to me, is coaching.
A lot of
people interchange coaching and mentoring.
They're not
the same to me. Mentoring is I tell someone
a story or
they tell me a story and I give them advice
based on the
story. But I probably don't observe them.
Feedback,
real coaching, requires observation because
in order to
know what skills you need to improve on, I've
got to
watch you, or I need to interview about ten
people who
do watch you. Okay? So most people are not
great
coaches because of this or don't do a great
job coaching
peers on a project team because they don't
do this.
Takes a lot of preparation, and the year-end
review is
not the time to coach. How many of you have
a year-end
review? How many of you give a year-end review?
Wow.
Okay. How many of you wait until the year-end
review to
give coaching? Now everybody's afraid to raise
their
hand, of course. Let me comment why. The year-end
review, in my opinion, that's the verdict.
The jury has
come in, it's the very -- the reason I say
it's the
verdict, it's too late to do anything to affect
your
compensation or promotion. People are not
really in the
mood. Think about yourself. Are you really
in the mood
to get coaching in your year-end review especially
if
you think there's nothing you can do about
it to affect
your promotion or your comp? And so what I
say is,
people should work on coaching during the
year, at least
three to six months in advance of the year-end
review.
All right? Now, more importantly for this
group, I
would argue it's -- it's 100 percent your
job to coach
people who report to you, but I would argue
for people
that report to you, or for all of you, it
is 100 percent
your job to get coaching. 100 percent your
job. And
most groups I go into when I ask who has a
coach, how
many people raised their hand? Who says they
have a
coach? Okay. It's a shockingly low number
of hands,
especially given in what I would argue is
a
leadership-oriented organization, coaching
is about as
important a thing as you can possibly do.
Why? Because
you've got vision, priorities, how you spend
your time,
and then the whole thing -- reason you coach
is to try
to get aligned -- align people and the organization
with
what you're trying to do. I would say to all
of you, if
you don't have a coach, go get one here. And
the way to
go get one unfortunately is to ask people
to give you
advice on what they think are one or two things
you need
to improve on. You actually need to go ask.
People
will not volunteer it. Why? Because they would
prefer
not to offend you, or they don't know if you
even want
to hear it. You may send off a vibe even though
you
want coaching that it's unwelcome to give
you advice.
And I would argue, you've got to ask. Okay?
And I
think if you ask people for advice, A, they
may be
flattered; and B, they may need to go do homework
for
two or three weeks before they can give you
something
sensible, but I would argue you should take
ownership.
I'd urge you to take ownership of getting
coaching. How
many of you are up for that? All right. So
then can I
ask a dumb question? What's stopping you from
doing it
other than no one's suggested it? What stops
you?
Anyone want to volunteer? What's stopping
you other
than no one's suggested it? What stops you
from going
and getting it? Anyone want to volunteer?
What stops
you from going and getting it?
[male audience member responds]
>>Rob Kaplan: Right. And so it's an awkward
conversation. All right. I agree with that.
So here's
my advice on how to to this. And you got to
get in the
habit of doing it, and sometimes you have
to train
people and let them know you want coaching.
First you
have to do it one on one. You can't do it
in a group.
In other words, you can't ask somebody to
give you
advice in front of other people because what
they're
really thinking they may not want to say in
front of
other people. Appropriate. Number two, you
need to be
clear with them that you're sincere and that
you want
the advice. And then you need to make sure
to thank
them for what they do. My experience is when
I started
doing that in my career, had to get people
going to give
me advice, and they knew when I -- because
I wanted it
they would watch me a little more carefully,
and often
they would come in and warn me, without me
asking, about
some area I screwed up in, which used to happen
frequently. Now, as you get more senior, I
-- I urge
people to go get junior coaches. So you work
at Google
now? [female audience member responds] Okay.
Good. Teak Fellowship. Sorry. I'm the
Chairman of the Board. Anyhow, that's another
story. [laughter]
But non-profit effort we have in New York
City. Okay.
So you have to train people to do this. But
it will
make you dramatically more effective and I
would argue
for the rest of your career, no matter how
senior you
get, you've got to get in the habit of asking
either
senior people for coaching, but as you get
more senior,
you've got to ask your subordinates for coaching.
Let
me ask one more question. How many of you
people that
are senior to you ask you for advice and coaching?
Okay. Good. And by the way, for those who
got asked,
what do you think of them? Think they're weaklings
or
what's your reaction? How does it make you
feel about
them?
>>Male #1:I like them that much better.
>>Rob Kaplan: You like them that much better.
And that's typical, by the way. It also -- it
makes
them better. So my point is, if you want to
be a
leader, leadership is about getting advice.
Now, people
don't always think that, or that's not the
first thing
that comes to mind when I talk about leader.
But the
great leaders I can tell you seek advice and
then they
listen to the advice, and they're open to
learning and
acting on it. And I argue, if you want to
be a leader,
you've got to do that. Yes, sir?
>>Male #2: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: It's -- so the question is,
written or one on one? My own --. Listen,
if it's easier for somebody to
give you advice well into the year in handwriting,
fine,
so that maybe it's safer. If they can do it
in person,
I'll tell you why it's great in person, because
you're
going to have two or three follow-up questions.
So
"Gee, Rob, you need to get better at blank,"
or "I don't
like the way you gave that speech." I'll say,
"Should I
have done this? Should I have done that?"
You'll
always have follow-up questions and it's a
conversation.
Tell me how I would do it, and then I try
it. But I
would urge you to do this and if senior people
are
asking you for advice, smart. That's a sign,
I would
argue, of an outstanding leader. All right.
Now, you
guys don't need to worry about this, do you?
Okay. So
I'm going to skip this for today, but let
me comment
about the people who are much more senior
in this
company, the few that I know. This is the
-- who do I
ask for advice from if I'm a senior person?
I ask for
people who are up and coming. And the truth
is, every
company has a succession plan. I am certain
this one
does. But the only advice I give to senior
people is,
use it. Now, you will get to a stage in your
career in
the not-too-distant future where you need
to start
thinking in everything you do, who's going
to take your
place? Some of you are probably already doing
that. I
was trained in my career it's something I
started doing
it after two or three years at the firm. And
it's a
great discipline to have because it caused
me to be a
better coach. All right. Let me go another
thing. How
many of you think you're a bottleneck? How
many of you
know what a bottleneck is, [laughter] other
than the picture I
pulled off the web? Which I kind of like,
actually.
He's what a bottleneck is. Bottleneck is sort
of things
are flowing smoothly -- you guys know all
about
bottlenecks [chuckles] -- and because of your
style, you slow
things down. Now, sometimes it's quite appropriate
to
be a bottleneck. Check with me before you
make a
certain level of decision. I think sometimes
if it's
important enough, perfect. You delegate to
people and
you say check back with me before you do blank.
The
problem is, there are two or three other types
of
bottlenecks. And by the way, I've never met
anybody
who's a bottleneck who thinks they're a bottleneck.
No
one thinks they're a bottleneck because your
input is so
valuable. [audience chuckles] It just has
to make things better. We just
know that. Okay. So here's an example. One,
you don't
articulate a vision with priorities and the
people on
your team are not clear for the project, or
the
department, or the unit. They're not clear
on what the
vision or priorities are. I would say if you
have not
done that, I assure you, you are a bottleneck.
And what
do I mean? Bottleneck impedes others from
figuring out
what they believe and acting on it; impedes
other people
from being leaders. And if you're freezing
people, and
they're waiting around, and they don't know
what to do
because you're not clear on the vision and
priorities
for a project, it slows everybody down or
it sort of
makes them wait for you to explain what you
want done
next. And so that's one kind of bottleneck.
Other kind
of bottleneck is you do do that, and you delegate
to
people, and then you second guess after they
make the
decision. And you so terrorize them that they
think
they're never going to make another decision
again
unless they check with you first. Another
one is, you
delegate to them and agree that so-and-so's
going to do
something, but then you get involved and do
it anyhow.
Okay. You ever see that one around here? Okay.
And all those
things slow things down. The only thing I
say to
leaders, are you a bottleneck and I think,
by the way,
the most important one is over-communicating
your vision
and priorities to everybody's clear on what
they're
supposed to do, and being a coach. By the
way, there
are a lot of people that are bottlenecks because
they
don't know what their peers or people they're
working
with think of them, but they get a bad vibe
that they
don't think too highly, and they're afraid
to act
because of it. You ever see that? This is
why I would
far prefer being blunt and direct and giving
feedback,
and then people know if you've got something
to say,
you're saying it. As opposed to talking behind
their
back or thinking something that you're going
to write in
your year-end review that you don't know about.
Okay?
If that makes sense. You know, a lot of people
think
being a leader is about -- and it is about
collaboration
and harmony, but sometimes it's also about
having enough
commitment to one another, and to the company,
and to
the organization to be confrontational sometimes,
and
maybe even make a few waves. I'll talk about
that in a
minute. Coaching is a little risky in that
way. All
right. Now, these next two things are something
you
need to do and I know this company does frequently,
and
I call it evaluation. Very simple. Do you
look at what
you're working on with a clean sheet of paper?
Do you
look at your career with a clean sheet of
paper? Do you
look at your project, your department, whatever
your
doing, with a clean sheet of paper; given
the world is
constantly changing, you're changing, you're
learning,
your team is changing, customers are changing,
competitors are taking actions all the time.
Successful
enterprises like this one are constantly looking
at if
we were starting from scratch, is this how
we'd do it?
This is a very difficult thing emotionally
to do,
especially if you get in the habit of doing
things a
certain way. And here's really what you're
asking: Is
the culture, the people we have here, the
way we're
organized, the way we pay, way we promote,
all that, the
way you're approaching the project if you're
a project
manager, is it still consistent with achieving
the
vision? Or is it not? And what happens, history
of
business, the reason that many successful
businesses
from 30 years ago and 50 years ago you've
never even
heard of? They go away? Is that they do not
continually do this. Because this is hard.
It's extremely
hard. And the reason it's hard is it's very
hard for
people to get out of habits. And what leaders
do in a
constructive way is jar people and give them
opportunities to say let's look at this with
a clean
sheet of paper. Coaching, I would argue, does
this. If
you're getting coaching all the time, and
you're asking
for what you need to do better, it's a way
for you to
jar yourself and say let me look at what I'm
doing with
a clean sheet of paper. Maybe I'm not going
about this
the right way. And all I'm saying to you is,
ask the
question. I don't know the answer, but I encourage
you
the ask the question. Yes?
>>Male #2: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Yeah. That's true. Yeah. Did
you hear the question? The question is, underlying
a
lot of this is trust. Right? Correct? Particularly
if
you're speaking up, if you're asking for advice,
you're making a few waves. And I would argue
that
fundamentally for each of us and each of you
when you
walk into this building, you fundamentally
every day
make a judgment. Do I feel comfortable here?
Can I be
myself? Do I trust the organization enough
to speak up
if I have something to say? Understand I got
to use
good judgment. If I'm talking, I've got to
pick my
spots, but do I have enough trust in the organization?
I would argue even with that -- how many of
you have
been in a meeting, by the way, where you're
nodding to
something someone senior person said, and
you don't
understand what they're talking about? Or
worse you do
understand and you totally disagree? Any of
you ever
done that? I've done it. So the question is,
why?
It's because there's -- even if you do trust,
there's a
little bit of I don't want to look stupid.
So there's
trust, do I trust that I will be treated fairly;
the
other part is, maybe I'm wrong. Maybe I'll
look like an
idiot. Maybe I'm not good enough. Gee, these
people
seem so smart. Maybe I'm not as smart as they
are. So
that's also an element of it. You have to
be confident
about it. To do what I'm saying, you have
to be
confident enough in yourself that you're going
to kind
of make the leap and realize yeah, occasionally
I'm
going to be wrong, and when I'm wrong say
I'm sorry, I
was wrong.Does that make sense? But you're
right.
There's an emotional part of this that makes
it hard for
people to make the leap sometimes, and you
want to work
at a place that encourages you to make the
leap. All
right. Now, this is a big subject I talk about,
which
is being a role model. And the reason I talk
about it
is the fact of the matter is, you can articulate
a
vision, priorities, you match your time with
your
priorities, you're a good coach, you get coaching,
you
do all the things I talked about, and unfortunately,
for
many people, including you, there's about
1 percent of
the time or half a percent of the time that
you throw it
all out the window and undermine all your
efforts. And
when is that for many people? It's when you're
stressed
out or when you're under enormous pressure.
And the
tricky part about this and it's hard to coach
people on
this is for each -- if there's a hundred people
in this
room--, what stresses each of you out is different
for
each one of you. I can tell you what stresses
me out,
what freaks me out. By the way, for me it
was when
people leave -- at my job when people leave
I
would go nuts. And so everybody who worked
with me knew
I was going to go nuts, and I had to learn
to calm
myself down a little bit. But I used to have
a joke
with all the department heads that reported
to me and I
used to say to them, "All I'm asking is for
you to know
what your people are thinking before they
think it."
[laughter]
>>Rob Kaplan: That's it. Because I want to
keep this team together. I want to build this
team.
Now, the fact of the matter is, though, for
all of you
there may be things that really -- that make
you at your
worst. And I'm not asking you to throw them
out here,
but I would encourage you to think of two
situations.
Think of -- think of when you're at your best.
When did
you shine? You were great. Okay? Write it
down --
write that down when you get a chance. What
were you
doing? Okay? What were you doing? What kinds
of tasks
were you doing? What kind of environment were
you in?
The flip side of that is, when were you at
your worst
when you were embarrassed by what you did?
Maybe you
made a mistake and you acted like it wasn't
you. Maybe
you made a mistake and you quietly blamed
somebody else.
Maybe something went wrong and you just didn't
know what
to do, and you're not happy with what you
did. Now, I
would argue as a leader it happens to all
of us. You've
got to manage those periods. The first way
of doing it,
understand what stresses you out. You have
to
understand yourself. Most important person
you manage
ultimately [chuckles] we talk about as a leader
is you. You've got
to understand yourself. Your strengths, your
weaknesses, your passions, when you're at
your best, but
in particular if you're going to be a role
model -- when
I say be a role model, it's not enough to
be a role
model 98 percent of the time or 99. Where
people really
watch what you do as a role model is the 1
percent of
the time when it's hard to be a role model.
Maybe
somebody you work with on your team made a
mistake and
you stood up and took responsible with them
and didn't
blame them. That's not so easy. That takes
some trust;
that takes guts. But I'll tell you, if you've
got
people working with you, that say, "I'd like
to work
with him or her again." I mean, that's fabulous.
It
really matters and leaders need to think about
it. And
I don't think it's too late or too early for
each of you
to think about that. What stresses you out?
When have
you done things that you were not pleased
with at all?
Why? So when those situations come up, it
helps to
think about it. This is the same reason, by
the way, I
ask people to think about their values, and
particularly
their boundaries ahead of time. Keep a little
journal.
Let me just finish. And think about it. I
will not
lie, cheat, steal. Think about it. All of
us get in
situations that are very persuasive. Either
a client, or a
boss, or a peer tries to push us to do something
that we
regret, and what helps inoculate you from
that is to
think about it in advance and when you see
those
situations, call time out. Slow down. Get
advice.
Talk to others. Elevate it. Okay? This is
what I mean
by being a role model. Yes?
>> Male #3: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Well, and here's the -- here's
the context that I'm talking about. So yes,
if a job is
not a good fit for you, fine. But you see,
as you're
a -- in a leader, you don't have the option,
as they
used to say, beam me up. You know, beam up.
You have
to manage through it. All of us as leaders
are involved
in situation where we're not -- this isn't
a great fit
for us. The trick is not how to get out of
it; the
trick is how to manage through it because
eventually you
won't be able to extricate yourself from it.
You
actually have to manage through it. Now, sometimes
that
means by building a team with complementary
skills but
in particular, this is really a character
issue for me
more than a skill issue. So I know there are
going to
be things I'm not good at. I already know
that. I'm
going to screw up. Can I admit that I made
a mistake?
That's what I'm talking about. Can I admit
that I don't
know it? I don't know. I'm not good at this.
Can I
admit it? Can I say it? Think of senior people
that
you work with that do that. What do you think
of them?
I think your first reaction is "Wow, this
person's
really good." I think it's impressive. Whereas
we tend
to think when we admit these things, I'm going
to look
like a weakling or I'm going to look like
I'm not very
good. And what I'm trying to say to people
is, our
conventional stereotypes of leaders, I don't
think
they're right. I think the truth is -- that's
with the
whole premise of this book. When I say it's
more important
to ask the right question, I don't think that's
our
stereotype of leaders who are, you know, giving
orders
or a President of the United States saying
I'm the
decider. Yeah, sometimes that's true, but
you've got to
be willing to admit what you don't know, build
your team
accordingly, understand your strengths and
weaknesses,
get advice, and I think you're going to be
dramatically
more effective. Are you being yourself? Those
little -- Alana was showing me the red dots,
and the
green, and about the food. I mean, so you
got to watch
what you're eating, know the calories. Let's
all say
it. I want you the feel like this is your
company that
we care about you that you can be yourself.
The problem
is, no matter how much the company does, some
of it's
got to come from you, and this gets back to
the trust
issue. And the one that I'm most interested
in is these
last two. Are you willing to confront, speak
up,
disagree? And I'm not a troublemaker, but
there are
times where if you just think your boss, or
the company,
or your peers are about to make a terrible
mistake, are
you willing to say, you know, "I don't think
I
understand what we're doing. I don't think
I agree."
Understanding -- you may be wrong, they may
beat your
brains in and make you feel dumb, but the
occasionally
got to do this I would argue as a leader.
This is the
essence of leadership. And there are some
people that
are so politically correct that it just -- you
know,
they think it's rude, or you know there's
lots of
reasons to talk yourself out of this but my
experience
is, you're going to be much more likely to
reach your
potential if you're yourself. And by the way,
I am
certain this company and companies generally
will do
dramatically better. The bigger the group
of people
that feel comfortable being themselves so
they can
assert themselves, you're going to have a
far more
successful enterprise. So let me stop there.
That's
really all this book is about. And all I'm
suggesting -- there's a lot more, obviously,
in the book
than this, but this is the thumbnail. Keep
five or six
questions on your wall. If you don't like
these ones ,
pick two or three others, but I think you've
got to --
when you're in trouble, which I get a raft
of people
come into my office or phone calls at Morgan
Hall when
they're struggling, at all levels: Former
students all
the way up to CEOs of companies, governors
of -- you
know, governors, public officials, all with
the same
point. I'm having a problem. And usually what
I do is
go through a series of questions with them.
All I'm
saying, have four or five questions on your
wall that
you're thinking about when things aren't going
well.
Now, you may think "but I hope I don't get
in a situation
where things aren't going well." Well, that
isn't going
to happen; you're going to. All of us do,
and all I'm
trying to do is help you with a road map to
how to
navigate through it and how to make your organization
more effective. All right. Let's go through
questions
now. Oh, come on. [light laughter] All right.
Yes.
>>Female #2: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Oh, God. Well, you know, some
things feedback is just heartbreaking. You
know, as
you -- the most -- the difficult one when
I was a junior
person I used to have occasionally a senior
person say
you know, you'll get your chance. Just tone
it down a
little bit here, you know, because I'd be
disagreeing.
That was okay. That wasn't so bad. What happens
-- you
know, everybody thinks as you get more senior,
you just
get more confident, and there's like nothing
can -- and
it's the opposite. As you get more senior,
you feel --
the senior people here and all of us seem
so confident
feel more vulnerable, you're more on a tightrope,
there's no net below, you got thousands of
people, I
fear I'm going to screw it up. And so what
happens is I
used to sit down with junior people and say
"Is there one thing I need to
do -- I can do better."I used to train people
to do
that. And they're very reluctant when you're
a senior
person to give you that advice unless they're
suicidal
because they think you're going to be offended.
So you
just pull it out of them, beads of sweat on
their
forehead, they think, "Oh, how am I going
to get out of
here, this guy." And they'd give you something.
And
they'd talk to you about a speech you gave
that wasn't
very good or something you did, and it's just
like oh,
it's devastating. Oh, my God. It's terrible.
So then
after they leave -- you try not to act too
upset. After
they leave you call a loved one, a friend,
and you ask
them, am I like this? And silence on the other
end of
the line. [laughter]
>>Rob Kaplan: And they go yeah. Yeah, that
does sound like you. And you go, oh, God.
Oh. So then
you have to go work on it. And the reason
it's so
devastating you realize not only does this
person think
it, everybody thinks it, and I'm so embarrassed.
I'm
mortified. Oh, my God. You learn though. By
the way, can you write down
on a piece of paper your strengths and weaknesses?
For
most of us it takes a lot of thought. I can
go to
everyone around you in your job and say "write
down that
person's strengths and weaknesses." Boom,
boom, boom,
boom, 15 seconds. And the truth is, the last
person to
know in your level and as you get through
the rest of
your career is often you, and the trick for
you is to
break through that. People ask about this,
"what's the
biggest enemy a leader faces or any of you
face?" Isolation.
Isolation. And you don't even know you're
isolated.
You know, people are thinking things, you're
not aware,
and you don't know to ask for advice, you're
very stoic,
you're afraid to disclose things about yourself
maybe,
which makes people feel less inclined to give
you
advice, and you get isolated, and that's when
you lose
perspective. And so a lot of these questions
are
intended to punch through that and get you
back
connected to people. Others. Yes.
>>Male #4: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Yes.
>>Rob Kaplan: Well, here's my -- first of
all, in my job, my argument, I have lots of
coaches and
I would say anybody who you think has observed
you
sufficiently to ideally have some constructive
observations on what you could do better,
they're a
candidate to be a coach. Okay? Then you just
have to
have the nerve to go ask them and say would
you mind
talking to me for 15 minutes or 30 minutes?
I'd love to
get your advice or observations on what I
could do
better. That's it. But to me, observation
is the key.
You want somebody who's seen you enough to
observe you.
I don't care whether they're senior, junior,
peer. And
I think people will respond very well to that.
And if
you have six, or seven, or eight or those
people,
listen, over the years I've had -- at this
stage of my
life--, I've had hundreds. You know, I'm finding
people
all the time. I walk out of class let's say
I pull some
poor person who was straggling behind and
say, "I want
to get your opinion on something. Did that
make sense?
Is there anything you'd do differently?" And
you know,
but I'm asking people for advice all the time.
Yes.
>> Male #5: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Okay. So the question is, what
about getting a coach who doesn't know you?
So here's
the issue. There are folks who don't know
me where they
can give me maybe some useful advice on some
things.
For example, I can go through with them, let
me tell you
my vision and priorities. Is that clear to
you? They
could answer that. Here's the concern -- here's
the
concern. So they're helpful, but on things
that you can
explain to them that they can give you feedback
In
addition, though, I don't think that's enough.
I think
in addition I work with lots of people and
I've worked
with lots of CEOs who say to me, "Oh, Rob,
I don't need
a coach. I've got thee outside mentors whom
I've known
for years, two whom work for McKinsey and
I tell them
what's going on, they give me feedback." Well,
as
they're saying it, they don't give them feedback
on the
thing they really need feedback on, which
is the way
they're acting every day, their leadership
style, that
they offend people and they don't know. They
don't know
it. They have to watch them. You'd never dream
-- I
would have never dreamed from just knowing
this person
in meetings that they act that way in their
jobs. I
wouldn't have believed it. You know? You ever
see
people like that? And so in addition to that
outside
person, you need somebody who observes you,
I believe.
Yes. Yeah. Sure. Right there.
>>Male #6: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Yeah.So the question is, what
tasks
do you choose to do yourself, what tasks do
you have
other people to do? So this is a project team
in this
case? All right. So here's a couple of questions
I
always ask. If we're just divvying up tasks,
two things I
decide. If I'm running a very large team where
I have
to review everybody's work, then I try to
only pick
tasks where I absolutely have to do it. Okay?
Because
I realize I need to have time to review everybody's
work. If, on the other hand you're all equal
and
working on a team, each think of your strengths
weaknesses and what you'd enjoy doing or what
would be
good for you to do; number 1. The thing that
I'm trying
to -- the thing I'm trying to point out, so
there's a
project task, and some of when you're on a
team -- I
would argue what I used to do and still do
when I'm on a
team, I'll do whatever needs to be done that
helps the
team. I will, because I feel that's what it
means to be
a teammate. Okay. Now there's one level above.
So
that's probably the right approach and mindset
at this
level. When you get to let's say you're getting
someday
where you're managing five project teams,
then you've
got to be much more -- here's the problem.
People have
struggled from being a team participant, to
being team
leader, to being multiple team leaders, and
what they
have to stop doing is a lot of those tasks
that they're
so great at when they were on a team, unfortunately
they
have to let those go, because if they do those
as well
as do the team oversight, they can't do both.
Or
they'll squeeze out people on the team. Or
if they
organize multiple teams, they won't do a good
job at
that. Their priorities much change in that
we're
overseeing the team might be more important
than doing
any one task. Does that make sense? So if
you're a
member of a six-person team right now, I'd
say do
whatever needs to be done that helps the team.
Simple
as that. It's that next step that I think
gets
trickier. Does that make sense?
>> Male #7: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: You're team leader.
>>Male #7: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Okay.
>>Rob Kaplan: All right. So let me answer
--
let me answer that. So back to that question
I asked
how many of you are a coach? I would argue
if you're a
team leader, all of a sudden if you're a team
member you
don't need to necessarily be a coach. Once
you're the
team leader, got to be a coach. So it means
when you're
allocating your time, money of your top three
or four
priorities is communicating vision, communicating
your
priorities, and coaching. Make sure whatever
you're
doing you leave time for those three. That
may mean
doing any one task you don't have time for
because you
figure out in advance I won't have time to
do these
other things. Okay? All right. Others. Yes.
>>Male #8: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Well, so there's two things
I
used to do, two questions I used to ask myself:
A,
always -- sometimes painfully -- what are
your strengths
and weaknesses? Okay? And what is my passion?
Hard
question to ask, that second one, because
things that
were a passion when I was 27, I found at 31,
I've done
it. I'm not -- this is not a passion anymore,
but boy,
I'd love to do blank. So those are the two
questions
there. And then there's a third question I'm
always
asking, including today: Am I learning? Am
I learning?
Am I learning? And if the answer starts to
be no,
that's when I think you start running out
of gas, or
worse, it's -- the opposite is bad. If I ever
get to
the point where I don't think I have any more
to learn,
then I really know I'm in trouble, okay, because
you
always do and so those are the three questions
I'd
suggest. Others? Yes.
>> Male #9: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: So you disagree with it.
>>Male #9:Yeah.
>>Rob Kaplan: Ah, sometimes I think it's
wrong. So here's the tricky part now. So we're
right
now talking about today how to be a good coachee
-- I
don't know if that's a word -- but first of
all, you got
to make sure first question, am I open to
hearing things
I don't want to hear. So you're trying to
encourage
people to tell you things you don't want to
hear who
care about you to do it, and are open to it;
and then
second, given if I say yeah, I am open, I
just think
that's wrong. Yeah. Some of the things you
hear in
coaching are wrong, but that shouldn't stop
you from
going and asking for it. So I would then get
five other
opinions and check it out. You know what I
mean? The
biggest problem I see with people is not that
they're
not able to improve. The biggest problem I
see when
people don't improve is because they don't
know what
they need to improve on. They're not open
to thinking
about what they need to improve on, and they're
not
going out and finding out. It's awareness;
it's not
ability. This is my experience and my belief.
99 percent of the time, if people know what
they need to
improve on, they're going to figure out a
way to do it.
God only knows how, but they'll figure out
a way. I've
seen it. It amazes me. So why don't they improve?
Because they don't know. They don't have two
or three
things that they know they need to work on.
So the
trick is, if you think that one feedback is
wrong, fine.
Find the two or three things that are right
that you're
going to work on, and go after those. Okay?
Go ahead.
>> Male #10: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Is this your boss? If it's not
your boss, you don't need to communicate that
they're
wrong, [chuckles] and in fact I might suggest
don't do that because
they're not going to feel like you're not
willing to
listen. If it's your boss, you might have
to
communicate that. If say if people give me
advice,
sometimes I don't always agree. I say thank
you because
sometimes they might come back and give you
advice on
something else later that you do think is
right and so
you don't want to shut them off. Now, if you're
a
senior person, you really need to say thank
you because
what I want is people to tell five of their
friends "he
or she is willing to receive advice. If you
got
something to say, go in there; he likes it."
So I want
to train people and create a culture where
people are
not afraid. Okay. Yes. Yes.
>>Male #11: [inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: Right.
>>Male #11:[inaudible]
>>Rob Kaplan: All right. So let's take the
second one first, then I'll go to the first,
which is a
profound question, the first one. We talk
about this
all the time. So how do you ask for feedback?
If
you're sincere, I think it'll come through.
Okay? So
as long as you're doing it for the right reasons,
if
someone's cynical and thinks you're just doing
it
whatever, kiss up to them, you can't do anything
about
that. I think if you're sincere, you'll be
perceived as
sincere. Now, the bigger question is, how
authentic can
I be? I teach a class called the authentic
leader, in
the fall. In fact, I just got done this week
teaching,
and this is the big enchilada, as they say,
in that you
need to be--, disclose enough about yourself
so that you
feel comfortable, and if you're a leader,
I would argue
you have to disclose about -- enough about
yourself to
encourage others to feel comfortable about
you and to
know you. We're always making a judgment about
where to
draw that line. There's certain things about
me I could
tell you that would make you laugh, would
make you
understand me better a little bit, but you
don't need to
know this. There's other fundamental things
about me
that I really should tell you if you're working
with me
because you'll understand me better. The trick
is, find
out which ones those are and the problem is
that some
people get them all mixed up. They disclose
all sorts
of personal information that don't help anybody
understand anything about where they're coming
from, and
they don't disclose the most important things.
So you
just have to use your judgment. And what makes
you feel
comfortable I would argue also is important.
Okay? I'm
sensitive to the time. Okay. Thank you, everybody.
I
enjoyed talking with you. Thanks for coming.
[Clapping]